[Musique]
sensation sensation le mag
bonjour à tous bienvenue sur sensation
en association avec TV 78 le 11 mai
prochain à repartage.com et stère Europe
organise la deuxième émission du swing
art Cup pour en parler avec nous je suis
aujourd'hui avec Christelle videaman
fondatrice star partage.com et Maggie de
Malawi président de la Société Ster
Europe bonjour bonjour alors cette année
c'est donc la deuxième édition du swing
art Cup elle se déroule une nouvelle
fois au golf de Béthemont à Poissy alors
la swing art Cup qu'est-ce que c'est la
swing art Cup c'est le rendez-vous des
constructeurs c'est-à-dire que
on réunit l'ensemble des acteurs du
monde du bâtiment c'est une co-création
entre art partage.com mettez de l'art
dans vos affaires Esther Europe donc le
bâtiment d'un côté tous les donneurs
d'ordre les promoteurs les architectes
les bailleurs sociaux et on y rajoute
une petite fantaisie on y rajoute de
l'art qu'est-ce qui vous a poussé
justement à collaborer ensemble pour
créer cet événement justement
c'est ce que je répète régulièrement
c'est que dans architecture les trois
premières lettres c'est là à RT donc a
c'est l'art de construire l'architecture
exactement
et donc ça souvent en attendant ça
l'oublier puisque aujourd'hui le monde
le monde d'aujourd'hui et les véritables
enjeux d'aujourd'hui nous amène à partir
essentiellement sur des sur des
challenges réguliers les andalas les
autres qui nous qui nous font un petit
peu oublier notre métier d'architecte
moi je suis architecte de formation et
c'est vrai que l'art doit reprendre sa
vraie place au milieu de l'architecture
et de l'art de construire donc c'est
finalement pas un mélange des deux
domaines mais c'est finalement se faire
réunir de domaine qui se ressemblent sur
sur certains points c'est un retour au
vrai valeur et aux sources de
l'architecture et parmi à la il y aura
des artistes un présent justement dans
dans le domaine de l'art Christelle
vidaman il y aura une portraitiste un
plasticien ou encore un photographe
pouvez-vous nous présenter ces artistes
présents et quels seront leur rôle lors
de cette journée
alexandrine langue qui est effectivement
portraitiste donc tout au long de la
journée elle va proposer des portraits
spontanés pour les participants donc
l'année dernière elle était
elle intervenait dans plusieurs endroits
mais les elle avait son chevalet c'est
ses crayons et les gens venaient se
comptent à des membres et l'avantage de
d'Alexandrine c'est que elle elle capte
tout de suite ce qui a au fond de la
personne donc c'est assez étonnant
toujours de voir une artiste qui là je
vais pas dire aux pieds élevé mais à la
main levée réaliser un portrait on a
également Hubert privé qui est qui nous
a fait l'année dernière
alors lui c'est il est un trophée majeur
lui il est bien bien connu sur le
territoire Saint-Quentin dans le monde
golfique donc c'est un sculpteur
et puis
la troisième personne c'est un
photographe qui en fait réalise fait des
captations tout au long de la journée
mais l'année dernière devant un
photocopole il avait réalisé des photos
de tous les participants et
on leur avait offert à la fin de
l'événement quelques jours enfin très
très peu de jours après on leur avait
offert leur portraits alors l'avantage
c'est que certains venaient avec ils
étaient certains étaient plusieurs dans
une même société et donc là c'était
s'ils avaient envie non pas d'être pris
individuellement mais par équipe c'était
vraiment tout tout se faisait tout se
fait spontanément ça il y a pas de alors
il y a un accueil quand ils arrivent
mais après il y avait des photos qui
étaient également prises tout au long du
parcours donc c'est
il rejoint un petit peu le l'artiste
portraitiste puisque il est capable de
capter aussi des mouvements
sur le parcours de golf avec tous ces
toutes ces personnes qui participent
alors pour cette deuxième édition
justement plusieurs activités seront
proposées donc on les a évoqués
notamment à travers à travers les
artistes mais il y aura également du
golf et principalement du Golfe est-ce
que vous estimez que le Golfe est un
sport fédérateur en terme d'échange et
de convivialité absolument le golf alors
on veut juste rajouter une chose c'est
que ce n'est pas un challenge de golf
que nous organisons mais une véritable
journée de rencontre autour du Golfe
c'est-à-dire dans un lieu
je dirais pas idyllique mais en tout cas
extrêmement sympathique avec beaucoup de
verdure avec des beaux paysages une
journée de détente où les personnes
peuvent se rencontrer au-delà d'un
bureau avec tout ce côté un peu formel
du bureau et du rendez-vous
professionnel là on est beaucoup plus
libre de tout en jouant et tout en
faisant quelque chose de ludique de
pouvoir les amateurs sans les bienvenus
par contre les vrais amateurs de golf
sont classés avec leur licence et ils
auront effectivement la possibilité de
faire des des parcours de golf à ce
moment là on organise on les met en
équipe de trois personnes on joueront ce
qu'on appelle en scramble c'est-à-dire
les trois personnes les trois personnes
formant l'équipe joue et on gagne à
chaque fois la meilleure le meilleur la
meilleure balle pour le trou suivant et
ainsi de suite et après à la fin de la
journée on fait les classements et en
distribue les cadeaux elle m'a guidée
Malawi vous êtes président de la Société
Ster Europe vous en avez un petit peu un
petit peu parlé au début d'émission pour
ceux qui ne connaissent pas
pourriez-vous nous en dire un petit peu
plus sur votre société bien sûr moi je
suis de formation architecte et
ingénieur stp j'ai fait pratiquement
toute ma vie professionnelle j'ai 66 ans
et j'ai fait toute ma vie
professionnelle dans l'ingénierie du
bâtiment en dirigeant de très gros
bureaux d'études sur l'Île-de-France
j'ai créé ma société stéro Europe en
décidant un petit peu de voler de mes
propres ailes j'ai voulu m'attacher
essentiellement à l'assistance de
maîtrise d'ouvrage puisque beaucoup de
maîtres d'ouvrage aujourd'hui selon la
législation sont censées être sachant
ils ont besoin de s'appuyer sur
l'expertise de personnes beaucoup plus
techniques et beaucoup plus se former à
résoudre les problèmes techniques sur
les opérations immobilières donc je fais
du montage d'opération j'amène ça chez
des opérateurs qui soient
institutionnels privés ou des promoteurs
j'ai autour d'une équipe que j'ai formé
également d'architecte de bureau
d'études et puis après j'accompagne tout
ce monde là et y compris le monde
politique pendant toute la vie du projet
jusqu'à la livraison de l'ouvrage et on
va revenir sur sur la swing art Cup donc
il y aura une portraitiste un plasticien
du golf quels sont les autres surprises
qui attendent les participants alors on
peut pas tout vous dévoiler
notamment probablement une surprise dans
le domaine culturel mais effectivement
une surprise reste une surprise
on avait l'année dernière on avait des
partenaires je tiens à repréciser qui
nous reçus cette année je pense à DLG je
pense à BMW je pense à une partenaire à
Mo si MB nature je pense
et oui parce que dans le mot partenaire
là j'étais en train de citer plus les
sponsors mais effectivement on a
également les entreprises qui nous ont
suivi pour la première édition et qui
resigne aussi dont effectivement il fimo
on a promoteur Olivier le savent c'est
très très difficile de
promoteurs
ce qui fait plaisir c'est qu'ils étaient
là présent à la première ils reviennent
donc ils ont aimé alors justement on va
revenir sur cette édition 2022 oui les
surprises
une petite chose qui pourrait
il y en a une concernant une société
viticole à romainvigny et là il y en
aura une sur le parcours et ça c'est une
vraie surprise parce que l'année
dernière on avait un partenaire mais on
était plutôt
on avait un stand et avec une
présentation de dégustation de ces
produits là on va avoir on a toujours un
partenaire 20 mais
qu'une petite surprise sur le parcours
pour tous ceux qui seront avec nous
tous les deux insatisfait justement de
cette première édition les sponsors et
les partenaires aussi finalement puisque
ils vous réaccompagne pour pour cette
pour cette deuxième édition est-ce que
vous pensez déjà la troisième édition
est-ce que c'est déjà en train de mûrir
dans votre vie
des surprises mais par contre je vais
vous livrer un secret allez-y
on n'a pas pu faire autrement que de le
reconduire cette année tellement on a eu
de la pression des gens qui l'ont vécu
et bien vécu l'année dernière on a eu
énormément de demandes ça a eu un très
grand succès grâce à vous d'ailleurs et
aux émissions que vous faites y compris
grâce aux médias tels que fairways qui
ont fait deux articles et d'autres que
je ne cite pas parce que voilà mais ça
me revient pas mais effectivement c'est
c'est voilà ça a été un vrai enjouement
un engouement pardon de et des vraies
demandes de la part de nos de nos
participants de l'année dernière pour
reconduire cette année 2024 bah écoutez
c'est un c'est une date qui marque un
petit peu tous les esprits ça va être
l'année de des Jeux Olympiques en France
on l'a reconduit on garde toujours le
mois de mai qui est un mois joyeux et
régulièrement ensoleillé on espère que
cette année on aura également du soleil
comme l'année dernière et voilà on est
on sera très heureux de le reconduire et
encore une fois peut-être en grossissant
encore un petit peu à chaque fois et ben
qui souhaitent justement que que du bon
pour cette pour cette journée donc le
swing art Cup c'est le 11 mai prochain
au golf de Béthemont à Poissy c'est bien
ça merci beaucoup Christelle évidemment
et Maggie de Malawi d'avoir été avec
nous sur sensation donc je rappelle
qu'on peut avoir plus d'informations sur
le site internet stère europe.fr et pour
vous c'est Europe pardon à partage.com
merci beaucoup à tous les deux d'être
venu sur sensation et pour revoir ou
réécouter cette émission rendez-vous sur
notre site merci et une autre
association et une autre application
pardon radio sensation
[Musique]